[Musique]
il n'est pas si loin le temps dans la
famille blancpain du cube le père
enregistrer ses émissions favorites sur
des cassettes vhs martin la mer plaçait
ses photos de famille dans un nouvel
album et laurent le fils écouter du rock
dans son tout nouveau baladeur
[Musique]
c'était les années 80 tous ces objets
ont progressivement disparu dans les
années 2000 laurence amis à entrer des
fichiers musicaux dans son smartphone
et martin a glissé des photos dans le
disque dur de son ordinateur
je pense que c'est quand même un progrès
phénoménal par rapport à l'album photo
au point d'ailleurs que toutes nos
photos sont maintenant utilisés et puis
dix ans plus tard nouvelle révolution
la musique et les photos ne sont plus à
l'intérieur des appareils qui permettent
de les lire mais loin bien loin
accessible à la vitesse de l'éclair par
internet ça m'est arrivé de bout du
monde d'avoir accès à mes photos et
quand je dis nous venons de c'était le
rajasthan mettre le mexique c'est quand
même fantastique effectivement il est j
alors si les photos et les chansons ont
déserté au disque dur ou sont elles
passées dans ce qu'on appelle le cloud
le mot anglais pour nuages un nom
poétique qui désigne la dernière
révolution d'internet le stockage à
distance
électronique qui héberge des millions
d'armoires concert
et pas seulement de loisirs à quoi
ressemble notre nuage
sommes-nous réellement propriétaire de
ce que nous déposions
sommes nous les seuls à y avoir accès
nous avons cherché à dissiper le
brouillard qui entoure encore cette
innovation la première fois que nous
avons entendu parler du cloud c'était
sur notre smartphone
quand nous avons découvert ce petit logo
il nous demandait si nous acceptions
d'exfiltrer de la musique de notre
appareil pour la donner au cloud un peu
méfiant nous avons d'abord refusé et
puis de mises à jour ont mis à jour
comme le logiciel insistait nous avons
fini par céder le téléphone serait
désormais en relation avec un nuage
dieu sait où un nuage capable d'héberger
une grande quantité de musique mais
aussi d'image ainsi que tous les
contacts de notre carnet d'adressés idem
pour notre tablette tactile le nuage une
solution en somme pour nos appareils
nomades
et bien pas seulement nos ordinateurs
fixes se connectent aussi parfois
voici stéphanie une jeune femme un peu
geek
hosoo lee qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça
le matin sur son ordinateur personnel l
échange de la musique avec son meilleur
ami à distance ils composent l'ensemble
des morceaux et travaille dessus à tour
de rôle la boîte aux lettres s'appelle
dropbox c'est ce qu'a toujours c'est un
espace de stockage qui est limité un
moment donné comme ces fichiers sont
trop lourds pour son ordinateur
stéphanie les confient à des serveurs à
distance on se dit que le nuage c'est un
maxi garde-meubles pour experts
d'internet
et bien pas seulement ensuite stéphanie
va relever ses emails comme nous tous
les matins on fait quoi hp connecte à la
messagerie et les e-mails aussi c'est du
cloud c'est à dire que c'est stocker
ailleurs quelque part sur un nuage
ça veut dire que je peux y avoir accès
n'importe où que ce soit sur mon
ordinateur que ce soit sion
et puis sur le chemin du travail
stéphanie fait ce que font des millions
de français elles sont une photo
voilà donc là je publie elle la poste
sur instagram flickr facebook le cloud
se loge dans nos actions des plus
banales au bureau ça continue stéphanie
travaille dans une agence de
communication
les logiciels qu'elles utilisent ne sont
pas reliés à un serveur privé mais au
cloud calendrier projets en cours
courier l'espace d'une matinée
stéphanie se sera branché sur une
vingtaine de nuages
nous qui pensions au début de cette
enquête vivre sous un ciel dégagé avec à
peine 1 ou de cumulus à l'horizon alors
qu en fait tous ces sites toutes les
applications dont nous connaissons par
coeur les logos stock nos données tous
là où c'est un peu mon quotidien c'est
un peu ma vie c'est un peu des bouts de
vie des bouts de ma vie donc c'est un
peu mon identité que je mets sur un
cloud des nuages qui savent tout jeune
et auquel elle accède avec un mot de
passe sur facebook vous le taper à
chaque connexion presque comme sur
dropbox
ou sur vos emails mais parfois pour
entrer en relation à des traîtres nuage
personne ne vous demande de vous
identifier
prenez le logiciel de vos appareils
nomades celui du fameux petit logo il
vous demande seulement la première fois
si vous autorisez la mise en nuage des
données par la suite vous pouvez presque
oublié qu'elles ont quitté la mémoire du
téléphone et qu'elle existe sans lui
malo à 18 ans il vit à fréjus et il a
l'habitude de déjeuner au fast food show
sans cesse il est parfois d'être un peu
étourdi comme ce jour d'août dernier
j'ai laissé mon portable sur le côté sur
le rebord de du comptoir
sans faire attention je me suis fait
piquer sur la je revenais de la plage en
maillot et accroche
après ce vol il suspend sa ligne
téléphonique et porte plainte au
commissariat de police
jusque là rien de très original mais
quelques semaines plus tard un curieux
phénomène se produit lorsqu il consulte
sa tablette tactile
je remarque qu'il ya des photos de
personnes cochonnet pas qui est qui
atterrissent sur un tablet
en tout plus de 200 images s'incruste
dans sa photothèque personnel souvent la
même personne
un adolescent des photos de lui des
photos de ses amis de ce qu'il fait ici
dans une voiture là dans une fête de
famille
comment est ce possible on dirait qu'ils
sont un peu plus
moi j'ai compris que c'était la personne
qui avait mon ancien comptable
en fait le voleur ou la personne qui lui
a racheté le smartphone a oublié de se
déconnecter du nuage auquel malo lui est
toujours reliée via sa tablette
au début je les ai vus et ça m'a fait
plus rire qu'autre chose de voir les
photos de quelqu'un d'autre je montre à
mes copains parents je me suis inquiété
un peu de savoir si si lui recevez mes
photos mais vu que il a pas l'air de se
soucier de toutes les photos qui fait je
pense que il reçoit pas mes photos je
sens embêtant pour lui que pour moi je
me suis retrouvé avec la vie de
quelqu'un sur mal aurait pu mener sa
petite enquête sur la base de ces photos
mais il n'a pas ressenti le besoin
l'assurance lui a payé un nouveau
smartphone
conclusion il faut bien surveiller
l'accès à son usage peut avoir plusieurs
portes d'entrée
d'ailleurs où se trouve-t-il exactement
ce nuage et comment fonctionne-t-il la
réponse est dans des data center ces
immenses entrepose électronique
sanctuaire d'internet en france il y en
a 130 tout dans celui ci arnaud est
responsable de l'hébergement c'est à la
fois le gardien en chef et le mécano en
chef du nuage
ils érigent ou 70 personnes au coeur du
club 3 à voir que c'est là on peut
stocker plusieurs pétaoctets de données
des gars de photos des milliards de
vidéos d'hédiard de musique et quand
vous réglez vos impôts par exemple
c'est ici que vous accédez à votre
déclaration quand vous consultez votre
compte en banque
c'est au bout d'un autre câble
en tout quarante mille sociétés
principalement françaises mais aussi
étrangères loue des armoires c'est à
dire des bouts de nuages dans ce
datacenter le nuage au final ces
infrastructures physiques réels ces deux
ordinateurs
c'est des gens qui vont les mettre en
connexion c'est les équipes qui vont
tourner h24 gérer la maintenance de ses
ordinateurs
[Musique]
parmi les entreprises locataires de ce
data center 10h01 services français de
musique en ligne
célèbre dans le monde entier la lumière
y est ingénieur il nous explique que
deezer a placé dans le cloud un énorme
catalogue de chansons qui tient dans
quelques machines
voilà donc ce sont ici que nous sont
stockés les tromperies langue titre de
10h15 les utilisateurs la volaille
musique ça passait par ces câbles ils
sont reliés à internet et on va renvoyer
tout ça on directement à l'utilisateur
pour qu'ils écoutent conservatrice il ya
les 30 millions de titres ce qui
représente pas loin mais c'est deux
millions d'albums
que deviennent qu'il en cas d'incendié
ou de bugs et bien ils ne sont pas
perdus car ils ont été copiés ailleurs à
l'autre bout du monde
c'est un principe essentiel du nuage la
duplication automatique dans d'autres
data center
ça permet aussi aux utilisateurs de se
connecter plus rapidement ses 30
millions de titres qui sont derrière ils
sont aussi copié à new york singapour et
à sin le noble utilisateurs dont il va
vouloir écouter sa musique et parce
qu'on était au data centre le plus
proche
donc s'il est en zone européenne il va
se connecter et j'attends ici
si les boutons indices collectés par
exemple à 6 mai grâce à ce système de
copie le nuage chargé de nos données est
donc toujours au dessus de nos têtes
où que nous soyons enfin
presque
nous retrouvons stéphanie elle s'apprête
à rentrer chez elle dans le métro elle
veut de nouveau prendre une photo alors
que nous sommes avec les contrôleurs de
la ratp
ouais j'ai été pris en faute
nous met dans le mien
et je vais même vous mais sur les
réseaux sociaux dans les achats sur les
réseaux sociaux
mallet pas de connexion je vais devoir
attendre qu'on sorte du métro impossible
pour elle d'accéder à son nuage
tous les jours elle passe une heure et
demie dans le métro et elle n'a que dix
petites minutes d'internet c'est
embêtant - métro de pas avoir de
connexion
parce que c'est là où je passe le plus
de temps et pourrait l'annoncer
on travaille dans mes planification
personnel etc
de nombreux passé
encore laissé leur nuage à l'entrée du
métro et un nuage qui ne répond pas cela
peut vous jouer des mauvais tours aux
pires moments surtout quand il contient
vos données les plus précieuses
[Musique]
direction washington dans une université
de prestige à la bibliothèque
joyce au domaine nous attend ce
professeur ne confiera plus jamais au
cloud
ces livres électroniques je peux l'a34
et parti lire mes livres précieux
réalise depuis les licenciés d'autres
qui motorise avec des yeux en août
dernier il doit partir à singapour
donnèrent une conférence il compte bien
utiliser les livres qu'il a achetés sur
internet qui la plaçait dans le nuage et
télécharger dans sa tablette
il prend l'avion
une fois à destination il prépare son
intervention vers l'ipad la société les
femmes les seins parce que j'ai un
contrat pour distribuer ses livres dont
un contre avec pêches et de sedan noir
en fait ces livres ont été effacées de
sa tablette et ils n'arrivent pas à
joindre le nuage il manque de rater sa
préférence
[Musique]
de retour à washington deuxième surprise
il n'arrive plus à arrêter les charger
sur sa tablette certains des fameux
livre parce qu'il a tenté de se
connecter de singapour
aujourd'hui encore il peine à les
récupérer ce que vous placez dans un
nuage semble donc pouvoir disparaître at
on des livres électroniques et ne soit
jamais vers eux pour bien comprendre la
mésaventure du professeur il faut
s'imaginer chez votre libraire favori
vous choisissez un livre
vous l'achetez vous ressortez ravi
et le libraire bien reprendre dans votre
sac ce qu'il vous a vendu mais avez vous
été bien attentifs ils n'avaient pas de
l'olivier commandes d'achat vous aviez
signé un document les conditions
générales d'utilisation les cgu un des
principaux pièges du nuage
[Musique]
hugo est un jeune juriste activistes
d'internet
il adore ce qui est écrit en tout petit
en cliquant sur inscription vous
acceptez nos conditions et indiqué que
vous avez lu notre politique
d'utilisation des données des politiques
qui sont parfois très surprenantes sur
le nuage d'apple par exemple où vous
stockez vos photos il faut savoir ceux
ci le contenu peut être supprimé à tout
moment sans préavis
l'entière discrétion de apple en clair
si vos documents sont jugées
inappropriées par les fournisseurs de
cloud
ils peuvent être écrasé et tant pis pour
vous n'est pas chez soi on est chez
apple c'est apple qui contrôle c'est
apple qui définit les règles du jeu
problème pour découvrir ces clauses
litigieuses
il faut avoir la passion de la lecture
des trois documents importants à lire
quand on s'inscrit sur les services
d'apple
pris ensemble et font que trente mille
mots c'est l'équivalent de 2 lire
partout chez les fourberies de scapin
d'un co et une fois que vous aurez lu
les conditions d'utilisation du nuage de
facebook de celui d'apple et de celui de
google vous aurait avalé tout ça selon
une étude américaine
il faudrait passer 25 jours sans dormir
pour lire les conditions générales
d'utilisation de tous les sites internet
visités pendant une année
la grande majorité des gens ne font pas
parce que c'est en pratique impossible
un nuage décidément qui a tendance à
nous échapper
souvent injoignable pas toujours fiables
nous allons voir qu'il est aussi parfois
bien vulnérable parce qu'il est protégé
par deux tout petit cadenas les mots de
passe aujourd'hui de nombreux pirates
sont capables d'en trouver la clé
voici stefan conseiller en cybersécurité
dans la vraie vie avec lui
nous allons faire une expérience accéder
à l'intégralité du nuage de son ami
nicolas qui ne sait pas que nous nous
intéressons à lui stéphane va forcer un
premier serveur unique reste peut-être
des données il a laissé son identifiant
sur un forum d'internautes
le pirate dispose d'un logiciel qui
retrouve les mots de passe de ce serveur
en testant des dizaines de combinaisons
à la seconde
j'ai un logiciel qui essayent plein de
combinaisons de mots de passe courant en
y ajoutant des chiffres et avec un peu
de chance son mot de passe et un mot
sainte du dictionnaire auquel il a juste
ajouté un chiffre cette combinaison très
courante
donc là on a trouvé son autre façon
votre place et rainbow arc en ciel en
anglais suivi du chiffre 1 stéphane a
maintenant la clé du serveur mais il n'y
a rien dedans alors le pirate vise la
boîte mail de nicolas et pour cela il va
entrer une nouvelle fois le mot de passe
trouvé ça marche
un internaute sur deux utilise le même
mot de passe pour plusieurs sites
stéphane va alors viser un étage
supérieur du nuage celui où nicolas
range ses documents les plus
confidentielles
on a ciblé un service de stockage en
ligne de fichiers dans le cloud qui
s'appelle dropbox
mais le mot de passe ne marche pas pour
ce troisième essai stéphane le pirate va
cliquer sur mot de passe oublié et
dropbox envoie automatiquement sur la
boîte email de nicolas un message
pour choisir un nouveau mot de passe
tonga à j'ai reçu le mail dropbox
je clique sur réinitialiser le mot de
passe et j'ai plus qu'à mettre un
nouveau mot de passe que choisit moi
même et je me log voilà et maintenant on
a accès aux fichiers que cette personne
a stockées dans le nuage
on a des factures donc là on a l'adresse
de la personne
on a son numéro de téléphone
hong hao son compte chez free et ce
n'est pas tout le pirate a devant lui un
boulevard où il trouve toutes sortes de
documents
c'est la somme de toutes ces
informations
une facture plus un bulletin de paye
plus des photos personnelles plus des
tas d'informations sur la famille sur le
prénom des enfants etc
tout ça ça va pouvoir être utilisés pour
monter un scénario d'usurpation
d'identité et faire quelque chose
derrière
mais sur le cloud les pirates limite
rarement ce genre de scénario sur mesure
souvent au début de l'expérience il ya
ce logiciel qui teste les combinaisons
et bien il est alimenté par des
centaines de millions de mots de passe
et de données volées par les hackers
comme récemment sur des sites tels
qu'adobe facebook google des pillages à
grande échelle
et quand les serveurs du cloud sont
attaqués cela peut faire de gros dégâts
alexandre français quelque chose il
travaille dans une start up qui met au
point des applications pour smartphones
dans le domaine du sport
la petite dernière vous dis par exemple
quel judoka a le plus de chance de
gagner un combat il y à un mois
alexandre veut faire un coup présenté
l'application grand public lors d'un
événement international
les championnats du monde de judo
juniors on avait plein de personnes qui
étaient sur place au championnat du
monde donc avaient été réquisitionnés
pour faire venir en italie pour saisir
toutes les statistiques pour les
diffuser sur grand écran pour les
envoyer aux entraîneurs pour les envoyer
à la presse donc c'est vraiment le loup
un logiciel qui était
le très officiel finalement mais les
choses ne vont pas se passer comme prévu
la compétition était un samedi et ont
servi le samedi matin et a plus rien qui
marche et l'application est hors service
en fait le nuage canadien qui l'héberge
pour et été attaqué par des hackers
même les copies de sauvegardes réalisées
seraient inutilisables
[Musique]
l'opération spéciale tourne au fiasco
et la start up d'alexandre manque de
couler en termes de chiffre d'affaires
concret sur un mois de clients s'est
effectivement entre 100 et 200 mille
euros perdus mais les répercussions que
ça a pour tous les contrats qu'on n'a
pas finalement conclu tous les clients
qui sont mécontents etc c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros de chiffre
de répercussions et pour une start up
qui a beau être en croissance qui veut
dire est ce une start up dont fragile ça
met en péril finalement la vie d'une
société la vie d'employé
tout ça pourquoi parce que parce que
ferran la technologie du claude n'était
pas aussi sécurisé qu'on l'espérait pas
aujourd'hui la start-up d'alexandre a
migré dans un autre nuage plus sécurisé
tous les nuages ne sont donc pas bien
protégé contre les intrusions et les
rois de l'intrusion
ce ne sont pas les hackers mais les
espions
[Musique]
ces derniers mois le nuage s'est
retrouvé au centre d'un ciel très sombre
le plus grand scandale d'espionnage de
l'histoire la sphère snowdon edouard
snowdon 30 ans est un ancien
informaticien de la nsa l'agencé de
renseignement américaine
en juin dernier il a commencé à révéler
les méthodes de ses anciens collègues
et depuis ils se cachent en russie
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes procuré cette interview de
elle est diffusée pour la première fois
sur une chaîne française
[Applaudissements]
les gens assis à mon bureau
j'avais autorités pour surveiller tous
les présidents surveiller tout le monde
le cloud a rendu ça possible depuis 2007
un programme permet à la nsa de
s'immiscer dans les nuages des
internautes étrangers comme vous et moi
des nuages hébergés par des sociétés
américaines
[Musique]
prism c'est le nom du programme est en
fait un moteur de recherche hyper
puissant il accéderait aux données de
google apple microsoft facebook avec
l'aval de ces sociétés dont les sièges
sont basés aux états unis
[Musique]
elle aurait signé un accord secret avec
la nsa à des fins antiterroristes
le programme est conforme au droit
américain encadrés par des juges
spécialisés dans le renseignement
même si vous ne faites rien hommage vous
êtes surveillés
or je n'ai pas besoin de faire quoi que
ce soit toi même par erreur un homme de
keanu cela ne s'applique à n'utiliser
succès cette saison le temple est plus
cher il faut des échanges avec des amis
et pousse à tacler sur sa taille et ses
citoyens que la nsa espionne grâce aux
accords prisme peuvent être de toute
nationalité sauf américaine l' agence de
renseignement n'est pas mandatée pour
cela au final comme le montre ce dessin
animé réalisé par un collectif franco
américain les données que les
internautes européens par exemple
laissent sur différents nuages peuvent
être consultées par toutes sortes de
curieuses
dans cette caricature ce que vous
écrivez sur twitter twitter le regarde
ce que vous postez sur facebook facebook
le regarde
quant à google
poussée d'un soutien vos données dans
les bras de la nsa qui les récupèrent
pour les stocker chez elle vaut nuages
sont très visités ce qui n'est pas sans
ternir la réputation du cloud américain
depuis la sphère snowdon
le secteur pourrait perdre jusqu'à 25
milliards d'euros l'europe par exemple
rapatrie déjà certaines données
et si pour les garder bien à l'abri dans
un nuage fermé à double tour
vous cherchez une bonne salle des
coffres direction la suisse à zurich
les champions du secret bancaire se
reconvertissent dans le secret numérique
comme cet informaticien qui a eu la
bonne idée
la suisse est un véritable paradis
numéro un c'est l'un des nombreux data
center de manipuler ils sont instruits
de nouveaux prêts georg à créer un cloud
ultra-sécurisé censés échapper aux
grandes oreilles de la msa un service
mail qui stocke aussi vos fichiers vos
agendas comme la plupart des cloud les
données sont dupliqués dans d'autres
data center mais cette fois tous
sont situées en suisse
depuis le début de la sphère snowdon
et orgue affirme avoir cette fois plus
de clients bien sûr que mes images aux
défis si quelque part en suisse
yes we can que vous n'avez jamais car en
suisse les données privées sont
particulièrement protégés mais que peut
la loi contre les espions étrangers
il y a aussi des espions étrangers à
jamais des nations can ainsi beaucoup de
on est absolument sur balles mais en
même temps il n'y a pas de voie légale
et leur donne accès aux données en
résumé d'après georg la nsa n'oserait
jamais transgressé la loi d'un pays
étranger pour y siphonner des données
mais nous allons voir que l' agence de
renseignement américaine s'autorise
quelques entorses au droit
fin octobre nouveau rebondissement dans
la sphère ce no 2 l'ancien agent révèle
un document explosif et ce post it
internes
il montre que la nsa ne s'est pas
contenté du moteur de recherche prisme
elle se brancherait sur le cloud de
google cette fois à l'insu de la société
et aspirerait en secret certains
échanges entre datacenters
nous avons rencontré bill bennett ancien
responsable de la nasa
on a passé 32 ans à l'âge où nous lui
avons demandé de décrypter ce post it et
surtout le petit smiley qui
l'accompagnent oh oui oh c'est à dire je
vois que quelques google de faire sauter
comme un jeu wii que personne ne soit au
courant
mieux encore ces captations illégales
auraient été réalisés en dehors du
territoire américain sans doute dans un
datacenter utilisé par google en grande
bretagne
les agents de la msa le soja n'aura donc
pas pour brancher leurs câbles en
territoire étranger
le seul conseil que je pourrais donner
aux gens qui utilisent le club tu mac
c'est au matin ne pouvait pas y faire
grand chose
alors si vous voulez que quelque chose
reste le privé alors forcément des gens
mais en tout cas des logiciels vous êtes
surveillés et si vous n'êtes pas dans le
nuage que vous n'avez pas internet
échappez vous à cette surveillance
mondialisée
vous pouvez vous retrouver dans le nuage
sans le savoir et nous allons vous
montrer comment à new york une
expérience de grande ampleur a commencé
en septembre 2012
gérer toute la ville à l'aide du cloud
et ce grâce au principal avantage du
nuage son immense capacité de stockage
pour accueillir toutes sortes
d'informations le cloud bouleverse par
exemple le travail des pompiers
[Applaudissements]
ils les aident à cibler les bâtiments
qu'ils doivent contrôler préventivement
tous les matins à la caserne de harlem
avant sa tournée d'inspection le
lieutenant queen s'en remettent à une
machine qui lui fournit automatiquement
des adresses avant tout fonctionner sur
du papier aujourd'hui c'est le système
qu'il me dit qu'elle bâtiment les ouest
et est ces listes et par ordre de risque
les risques d' incendies sont calculés
grâce aux données que les 900 milles
immeuble de new york propulse dans le
nuage
l'année de construction du bâtiment
le nombre de personnes qui y vivent et
leur niveau social basé sur les montants
des loyers et le taux de criminalité
[Musique]
c'est le nuage qui fournit sa feuille de
route au lieutenant queen je connais pas
trop si je sais mon gars c'est que
désormais à nous fait vraiment peur
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin lille
m two new york dans le cloud c'est
l'exploit d'un homme à la mairie michael
flowers un juriste de renom spécialisé
dans la collecte des données
pour ce projet il s'est entouré des
meilleurs analystes du pays
quand elle a commencé l'équipe à d'abord
réalisé qu'elle était assise sur une
mine d'informations si vous y
réfléchissez bien c'est là dans un
bâtiment et toutes les informations qui
sont dans le nuage ne vont pas servir
des soldats du feu loin de là ils sont
taxés reconnecter à un niveau en sortent
jamais aux vrais débridée avec truc
autant de services qui fort de tous ces
renseignements pourront mener l enquête
sur vous et cela ne fait pas polémique
aux états unis
il n'y a pas de commission informatique
et libertés alors que ça fait exactement
ces agents des citoyens new-yorkais
sunrise est le programmateur du cloud de
new york
nous lui donnons l'adresse du bâtiment
inspectés par les pompiers un premier
nom apparaît voyons voir ce vote
sa femme ou sa soeur regarde comme ça on
peut voir sur elle c'est il ya aussi des
informations ici un logiciel capable
d'identifier des couples sunrise peut
même savoir s'ils ont des impôts en
retard
le secret du nuage de new york c'est de
croiser plusieurs données et de les
faire parler
tiens à porter plainte contre sa
personne pour que vous entrez en ce
qu'il sait déjà de citoyens mal garé
votre nom figure dans le cloud de la
grande pomme
quand on sait que 100000 amendes de
stationnement sont émises chaque semaine
cela fait du monde là dedans et pas
seulement des internautes
l'expérience new yorkaise suscite un
grand intérêt dans le monde entier